good morning hickets tuesday so i love
visual art i think it is good and
helpful to have stuff on your walls that
connects you to beauty and wonder and
awe but one thing about art is that it's
often very expensive and another thing
about art is that the art world can be
kind of uh gross you know headlines like
paul allen's art collection to be
auctioned for a billion dollars does not
make it feel like art is for normal
people but i promise it is so first off
art does not have to be expensive like
one of my favorite artworks in our home
is this print by nathaniel russell
demanding snake poems now i love it
because it's beautiful but also because
posters tend to make political
statements or encourage consumption
habits and this poster just wants snake
poetry and i like to imagine rallies for
snake poetry where people are like what
do we want snake poems when do we want
em
but anyway russell's prints are
available on his website for forty
dollars and there are similarly talented
artists all over the world who have work
available many even do commissions via
instagram or twitter and if you want to
get really inexpensive art you can go to
like thrift stores and garage sales and
often find unique works there and you
can make a good thrift store painting
great by adding some star wars like dave
from dave ruinsart.com those by the way
his prints are 20 also you might think
art auctions are only for rich people
but there are art auctions on ebay all
the time and also on artsy.net where for
example right now there is one
fundraiser auction with an artwork by
michelle grabner one of my favorite
artists that's available for 300 which
is a lot of money but if you look at it
every day for 50 years it's only two
cents a day now i know what you're
thinking john you just turned 45 you're
not going to look at anything every day
for the next 50 years thank you thank
you for bringing that energy into the
video back to art for me artsy is like
zillow for art it's a great place to
just like scroll through and get a sense
of what you like and what things costs
and what galleries or artists you might
want to follow now there are two big
auction houses sotheby's and christie's
that make almost all of their money
selling like rolexes and warhols to the
world's richest people but anybody can
visit their websites and i like to visit
them partly so that i can think wow
somebody's gonna spend a hundred million
dollars on this painting by claude monet
and then store it in a windowless
storage facility wealth is a hell of a
drug but also not everything is monet
expensive like one of my favorite
impressionist painters is eugene bowden
who was one of monet's teachers and
whose works on paper sometimes sell for
like a couple thousand dollars which is
a ton of money obviously but it's 150
000 of what a monet costs plus it's just
fun to look at the art and if you zoom
in and make the images full resolution
and click around a bunch that costs
other bees and christies some hosting
money which they pass on to their
gajillionaire customers so it's like a
very indirect tax on the rich okay and
then of course there are art galleries
and local art centers and art schools
where works are often for sale also
there are art fairs where you can see a
curated selection of lots of different
artists like this weekend in
indianapolis is butter an annual art
fair featuring black artists from
indianapolis and around the world there
are also djs and artists workshops and
lots of other stuff it is overwhelmingly
the coolest thing that happens in
indianapolis and i'm not just saying
that because sarah's part of the
curatorial team so if you live in
indianapolis there's butter but wherever
you live there is so much cool art for
me the art that means the most to me is
the stuff that i connect to personally
maybe that's because i see a painting
that looks the way ocd feels to me or
maybe it's because it's art made by
someone i love like my favorite work of
art in our home is this painting that my
mom made of the la-z-boy where i wrote
looking for alaska it just brings me
such joy and solace and i hope that you
have or find art for your walls that
does the same for you hank i'll see you
on friday